i
would say just a little bit about the
notion of fractals generally because
this word
has been tossed about here much
and it's important to understand it
fractals are self-similar curves
that means they're uh
objects made of tiny of the
tiny versions of themselves
that's all it really means
and they can be quite
simple mathematical objects such as
a circle
the curve of a circle
is curved uh in the same way no matter
how large or small a portion of it
you look at it has this fractal quality
and but most fractals
are very complex a common example of a
fractal in nature
is
a fern
or a feather
you must have noticed how a fern is made
up of little fern-like
structures which are made up of still
smaller fern-like structures coming off
a vein
and and some ferns have four or five
levels of these little ferns
declining
uh
until
fairly recently these kind of curves
which were really discovered and
described in the late 19th century
were pretty much ignored they were
called pathological
curves the reason being that it was felt
that their mathematics was so
complicated that their end states
couldn't be calculated and so they were
called pathological
what this
this all changed with the
invention of computers because there are
not problems so complicated that
computers can't solve them so suddenly
the pathological curves which before had
been very hard to visualize at all it
became possible to create animated
computer graphic movies of these things
and what was
amazing about them was some families of
these curves
had
looked like
river deltas
nerve branchings
tree
lines
coast lines
island chains there were was this an
astonishing tendency for some families
of these curves to look like natural
objects
and at first nobody knew exactly what to
do with this
ibm has programs that produce endless
landscapes
you just fly above snow-capped mountain
ranges with alpine lakes and then lower
altitude areas with river cut uplands
and then more mountains and more lakes
and more deserts and more rivers and it
just goes on and it's being created from
a few lines of computer code
in a raster scanning graphics system
and
immediately natural scientists grabbed
onto these things
to describe aspects of nature that had
been previously outside the realm of
calculation because you can perform a
certain kind of
here we are
a certain kind of almost magic
with these things as an example of how
it works
once that ohio foundation we were on a
at point saul
which is a huge beach near vandenberg
air force base
and it runs for miles with the long low
sand dunes coming in and i was walking
on this beach and it was swept clean
i mean it was virtually there was
nothing on it and i came upon a heavy
black pebble
and i noticed this heavy black pebble
sitting there with a little pattern
around it it had obviously been detox
deposited by the incoming tide and i
kept walking along this beach
and after about a while
i came upon an identical
black pebble just like the first one and
i then i had
a stroke of insight or the logos tapped
me on the shoulder and i decided i would
perform an experiment
and i at the second black pebble
i count i turned
and retraced my steps
and i counted my steps
until i had returned to the first black
pebble it was like 723
steps
and so then i continued walking
and
730 steps later there was an identical
third black pebble sitting
on the beach
well
if i had had some credulous person with
me
i'm sure i could have won big money by
this method but
what is happening is not mysterious at
all it's that the sea
rolling into this huge bay
represents a very large unresolved set
of equations for chaos and turbulence
and it sorts itself out
in such a way that there are
hierarchical patterns of movement and
force in the tide
such that
every 725
steps give or take five steps the
equation solves itself in such a way to
deposit a black rock on the beach
well
this is this verges on almost natural
magic or something and what it allows in
the hands of
modelers
cybernetic modelers is
the possibility that very very complex
natural systems
such as the drainage of river basins
the energy economy of a rain forest or
something like that will be found
to resolve itself into rather simple
kinds of mathematically describable
objects
now
the
thing to notice about fractals is the
way they do their magic is they have
nested they are nested the same set of
perturbations or the same set of value
changes are nested again and again
into each other on many many levels
and
so that what is implied
if we say that there's a fractal
description of the rain forest and
there's a fractal description of river
systems and there's a fractal
description of the coastline of the
continents
what that implies is that there
therefore must be a fractal in which all
of those fractals are somehow subsets
and that the planet itself is some kind
of fractal uh
object
well to my mind
i mean that's all now agreed on by these
guys like mantle brought and pikekin and
the people who are working with all of
this but to my mind the the next step in
that
is to extend the notion of fractalness
to
time
and and so one of the things that i want
you to notice about time wave zero is
perhaps whether it is
quote unquote true or not
the way in which it uses fractals to
describe
phase transitions in a temporal medium
implies to me that this method
has great promise whether the values
that i've plugged into it
are true
or not
uh
i think i said at the beginning of this
you know this funny perception that
every day is somehow like every other
which is different from the every day is
made of four other days bit but every
day is rather like every other
and every week is rather like every
other week and every year and every
century and every million years is
rather like the one that came before
generally that's the rule
but what the fractal shows is how you
can have this
repetition
and everything embedded in sameness and
the momentum if you will of the
morphogenetic field and still have
occasionally completely astonishing
events occur
that's the thing how to
how to
save the phenomenon of extreme
perturbation and still be true to this
tendency that the universe has to smooth
all perturbations so i wanted to just
call your attention to the fact that
this wave that we are discussing is
a fractal
fractals are um
described by mathematicians as occupying
intermediate dimensions
they're what's another name for them is
space filling curves
would you say it's a fraction of the
dimension
yes that if you ask what is the
dimension of the fractal you will be
given a number between one and two
like
1.365 these
these things
occupy an intermediate zone they are
neither
quite two-dimensional nor entirely
one-dimensional or quite
three-dimensional nor entirely
two-dimensional and it's this
inter-dimensionality of the fractal also
that holds possibility i think uh what
did you say
about being intermediate it occupies an
intermediate dimension between whole
numbers and now linguistic analysis is
being carried out
that shows that
syntax
is fractally organized that the act of
creating language is the act of running
a fractal generation program
in the human neurological system and
that somehow if you analyze
speech
hours and hours of speech god knows i'm
aware of the fractal nature of speech
because i'm always in the same place
saying the same thing
but it's
always a little different
well anyway
i i
the fractal thing if you've not heard of
it before you heard it here first and
it's going to give very powerful
mathematical tools to us for the
description of reality you see really
until the fractals were legitimized by
high-speed computers the only objects we
had to describe nature were the classic
aristotelian solids
the cube the perfect sphere the ellipse
the rhomboid the parallel that was it
and you know 2500 years we've been
trying to get along with that and
obviously these things do not describe
nature very well that was the whole
problem that hung astronomy for a
thousand to fifteen hundred years
that they had perfect circles to
describe the motion of the planets and
the planets all moved in ellipses so
then to get their perfect circles to
work they had to invent the ptolemaic
epicycle which was this excruciatingly
inelegant way of causing an ellipse to
appear to be a system of perfect circles
if you want to see an example of a great
mind anticipating a mathematical
breakthrough
you all know the wave by hokusai
writes the great japanese printmaker
well sometime next time you see it
look at
the place where the wave is coming over
the top and beginning to break apart
because what you'll you have this one
wave coming up
and then it divides into two
and then they divide each into two and
each into two and there's this wonderful
fractal drip
on the lip of the wave that you know is
the product of keen keen observation
also leonardo da vinci
believe it or not did a series of
drawings
of of uh
turbulence
can you imagine drawing turbulence
he would drop he would drop ink
in glasses of water
and then draw it and he drew it with
such an attention to detail that the
fractal nature
of turbulence of that sort is visible in
the drawings and of course there was no
name for it or anything he was just had
this guy had such an eye
you know the fractals there isn't a
classic place in it what made them very
exciting to me
was when you give them to a good
computer and it generates these things
for you they look more like
hallucinations
than any art of the huichol or the
wetoto or i mean these things look like
hallucinations well so that's very
suggestive because you be you think
uh you know these mathematical objects
look like hallucinations do
hallucinations look like these
mathematical objects because the nervous
system is organized this way and we're
somehow getting an
or organizational insight into how
either the physical matter is arranged
or how the data is being handled
and
and this may be the key you know if
language turns out to be fractal well
then this is the key to understanding
learning
memory
it sort of explains how we can be in the
world because what it's saying is you
know if you find out about this
square yard of ground
you're in a much better position to deal
with all other square yards of ground
not a perfect position but in other
words that local information has global
implications
that would be the way to put it
i don't quite understand the fractals in
language what is it that's being
repeated is it tones or what is the
pattern
well um
uh syntactical patterns patterns of
subject object relationship modified by
phrases in a certain way the fact that
adjectives perceive normally what they
modify
yes exactly that there are these
patterns and
you know one of the great problems of
computer artificial language theory is
and noam chomsky wrote a lot about this
the problem of getting a machine to
recognize all possible sentences
as sentences
we
seem to have we do this quite naturally
i mean every day if you live with
exciting people you hear sentences which
were probably never before spoken in the
history of the world and yet you
immediately understand that this is a
sentence but getting a machine to
achieve this kind of linguistic closure
is very difficult now with the parallel
processing machines and fractal analysis
of language they think they're going to
get it but what we may pardon who knows
about it
who does this kind of work
[Music]
well the language laboratory at mit is
doing a lot of it a fair bit of it is
classified because it revolves around
the government funds what are called
machine translation projects and that's
doing the spade work for artificial
language projects they want to have
voice controlled fighter aircraft and
stuff like this
and
you know they begin with very simple
vocabularies but the idea is to build
out and this kind of effort will not be
successful unless we really know what
language is because we're trying to get
down on the nitty-gritty of it
the the fractal thing
is uh
it's it's very interesting i mean it has
implications sociologically
for our own psychological
self-imaging
for planning
and yet once grasped it's a very
simple uh notion and i believe that you
know it's reinforced by the natural
world that everywhere we look
there are cycles energy cycles
astrophysical cycles the spinning planet
but we
we have for a long time seen these
things as cycles but we've never seen
them as
repeated repetitive modules
of large fractal systems which is what
they really are it isn't that the earth
always goes around the sun the same way
it's that it more or less goes around
the sun the same way and nested uh
systems of fractals you know the iching
uses this wonderful phrase
pre-potent systems of relationship
and says you must not come into conflict
with pre-potent systems of relationship
this means do not walk into closed doors
now if the door is closed please open it
before passing through otherwise you get
a bump on the head
and knowing that the universe has this
this fractal structure
uh
makes it possible to navigate through it
even if you don't buy into this
particular version of it uh fractal
metaphors fractal ways of thinking about
things are
going to make life much easier to live
in the future
i think it was janice joplin or some
people say andy warhol and that proves
the point before i even tell the
anecdote
anyway one or the other of them said in
the future everybody will be famous for
15 minutes
well this is a perfect exemplification
of
a fractal sociological point of view i
mean whichever said it they were quite a
master
these computer graphic movies of
fractals it look it shows you what looks
like a mountain range running down to
one side of the screen and the camera
focuses in on this point in the side of
the screen and mountain range flows out
of it for as long as you care to look at
it hours days weeks it doesn't care just
keeps
blowing up this point and you see more
and more
landscape
this notion of local information having
global implications
is a
a cardinal principle of shamanism
you see the idea and it's exemplified in
volume and private and all this talk
about calligraphy and
all this it's that locally is the
information that you need to have
to understand uh distant situations it
is all
there and it is it achieves this
through a basic
organizational principle the holographic
the hologrammatic the fractal enfolding
of information so that
no matter how small a piece of the
puzzle you have
if you
meditate deeply enough the entire
pattern can be
extracted out of it and i think this is
what wisdom must be in life
it's the ability
to be handed a
situation you know your daughter's
running off with the hell's angel or
your bank account is overdrawn and
knowing how to solve it by fitting it
into the totality of things i mean
usually the first step is to relax
and i maintain you know that these kind
of theories
promote and
give permission to
abandon anxiety
that they
say
it's all right you know it isn't
it isn't riding on
the egos of civilized people it isn't up
to us to control and understand we are
uh we are part of a system but the
system
is in governance of the situation it is
not running out of control it has not
escaped its traces and
is in some
a
malfunctioning state it's just that it
is a process of winding things up
in order to condense them down
in order to push them into another
dimensional domain where everything is
connected to everything else and
therefore
everything is at equilibrium and
completion
om shanti
there it is in a nutshell
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
you